everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and i wanted to let
everyone know that i just launched a new
channel and a new website and since i
did launch and I decided now would be a
good time to give away some free stuff
to those who follow me on the chess
website channel so with that said the
info for the new channel will be in the
section to your right and it's the map
world so you can click the link to your
right or you can just search youtube the
math world and the website is the math
worldcom and so the math world looks
like this if y'all were always curious
hey I wonder what that Kevin guy looks
like this is me and i'll be teaching a
lot of math tricks and later on i'll be
getting into pre-algebra algebra
calculus precalculus geometry so if you
want to learn some math tricks or you
have someone that wants to learn math in
general on different subjects i'm going
to be teaching that and starting with
math tricks so this is the channel right
here and the math worldcom looks like
this you can go there and check it out
and it's pretty cool nice little design
you can come here and if there's a trick
that you like you can read about it
watch a video you can do some problems
get it right check mark if you're wrong
it'll give you an X so it's a pretty
cool website you guys can check it out
but the giveaway I'm actually going to
be giving away some chess books and some
books that I wrote myself and the chess
books i'm going to be giving away i'm
probably going to be giving away two but
i'm going to be giving away two copies
of chess tactics chess tactics for
champions I'll know if any guys have
read this book but I try to read quite a
bit of chess books and this is one of
the better chess books that I've read so
I want to give a few copies of this book
out and I'm also going to give a
few copies of my book out since I have a
lot of copies laying around here at home
which is tic tactics I know it's not
chess it's tic-tac-toe but it's still a
pretty fun book so I thought I'd give
that away for free so here is what you
have to do to be eligible to win and I'm
going to be giving away quite a few so
you'll definitely want to do this first
thing you have to be a subscriber to the
chest website and you also have to be my
friend so if you subscribed and you're
not my friend yet just throw me a friend
request and i'll accept it and the same
goes for the math world you've got to
subscribe to the math world and you've
got to be my friend on the math world
and what i'm going to do is a week from
today so februari 18th at 10pm eastern
time wherever that is for you i'm not
sure but februari 18th at 10pm i'm
actually going to videotape me this
taking the selection process so no one
tells me that I cheated or anything but
I'm actually going to look randomly draw
subscribers from the math world and I'm
going to then look to make sure they are
one friends with me on the math world
and to their subscribers to the chess
website and their friends with me on the
test website so the only other thing
that I will say as far as the
competition is since today is the 11th
that you can't have a youtube account
that was signed up after the 11th so
don't watch this video and go sign up 10
different accounts because it won't be
eligible I really want people that have
actually been following me on the chest
website to be eligible so
only accounts that are active right now
are eligible and you've got to subscribe
to both channels and be friends to bow
channels so and as you can tell from the
prizes they are chess books and my books
so they're really just for you guys this
channel has been awesome and I just want
to let you guys know about the new
channel and the new website so leave
feedback let me know what you guys think
of the new channel the new website and
good luck to everyone in the competition
I'll see you guys next video